in other videos we have talked about the
various empires of india as we exit the
vedic period we talk about the morya
empire famous for the ruler ashoka who
converts and then spreads buddhism as we
get into the common era we've talked
about the gupta empire that once again
unifies much of india and is considered
a golden age in india's history
but after the fall of the gupta empire
india fragments and you could roughly
consider this to be the indian medieval
period this is what india looks like in
the year 1000 where you have multiple
hindu kingdoms
now as we get into the second millennium
of the common era you start to have
significant muslim influence at first in
the northwest but as we get into the
late 12th and early 13th century you
have the establishment of the delhi
sultanate and once again north india is
now unified under muslim rule which will
continue for some time under both the
delhi sultanate and the mughal empire
until the british show up and then
eventually in 1947 india becomes an
independent country but as much
transformation as there is depicted in
this map in terms of various empires and
rulers you also see a transformation in
the nature of hinduism
in other videos we have talked about the
vedas composed over 3000 years ago in
the subset that is focused on the
metaphysical on the spiritual known as
the upanishads and this is an excerpt
from the isha upanishad which is
considered one of the most important
that emphasizes this notion of our inner
self capitalized with an s atma or atman
and how it is of the same substance as
this formless nameless ultimate reality
sometimes referred to as brahman
the wise man who realizes all beings is
not distinct from his own self atman and
his own self as the self of all beings
does not by virtue of that perception
hate anyone
what delusion what sorrow can there be
for that wise man who realizes the unity
of all existence by perceiving all
beings as his own self and so you have
this very abstract idea some folks would
call it monistic all is one your true
self is of the same substance as my true
self which is of the same substance and
is the same thing as the ultimate
reality
but the vedas also focus on rituals and
there are also gods in the vedas
in particular some of the gods that are
mentioned most frequently you have indra
who is the god of lightning and the god
of storms
also referred to in the vedas as the
king of gods you have agni the god of
fire it comes from the same root word as
ignite
you have varuna the god of water
but a question how do we bridge that to
the gods and the practices of modern
hinduism
as we've talked about in other videos on
hindu deities most hindus today view
themselves as devotees of shiva or
devotees of visnu
and even though visnu is mentioned in
the vedas he is by no means the focus
modern hindu practice is really focused
on devotion to shiva
and or vishnu or
aspects of them or incarnations of them
for example rama or krishna
so how did hinduism evolve in this way
and the answer is the bhakti movement
and the word bhakti can be translated as
devotion or devotional love and it is
believed to have come out of south india
in the 7th century some people would
call it a reform of hinduism that up
until that point focused on the somewhat
arcane rituals of the vedas and the
bhakti movement provided an alternate
path a path of devotion through devotion
through a deity
one can achieve that moksha so some
people would consider it a reform
movement some people would say it was
always there some historians think that
it might have even been in reaction to
muslim influence where there was this
devotion or this surrender to a notion
of god
some historians think that it
co-developed with sufi islam which is
all about devotional love for god
but needless to say
as we go through the indian middle ages
the bhakti movement gains more and more
momentum and is really the defining
movement for hinduism today
and just to get an appreciation for
some bhakthi text
here is an excerpt from the
bhagavad-gita which is considered by
many modern hindus to be one of their
most central scriptures it was likely
written over 2000 years ago and really
came into its final form during the
gupta empire but the gita is considered
one of the central bhakthi texts
and even though the gita does focus a
lot on notions of realizing the self and
the ultimate reality and the importance
of meditation it also makes clear that
there's a path to self-realization
through love through devotion
this is krishna the eighth incarnation
of vishnu talking to
the archer arjun as he goes into battle
it's a bit of a repudiation of what at
the time in medieval india was becoming
a more and more rigid cast structure
i look upon all creatures equally none
are less dear to me and none more dear
and it is also very inclusive it is not
saying that one needs to only worship
vishnu or only worship shiva those who
worship other gods with faith and
devotion also worship me
not a fixation on being
absolutely true to all of the rituals in
the vedas whatever i am offered in
devotion with a pure heart even if it's
a leaf a flower fruit or water i accept
with joy
with that i'll leave you with a bajan a
big part of the bhakthi movement of this
notion of devotional love to god is
singing
[Music]
oh